the College Admission scandal the former
CEO of one of the world's largest
investment management companies was
sentenced in Boston to nine months in
prison as Carter Evans reports it's the
harshest penalty handed down to any
parent in the scandal so far of all the
parents swept up in the college
admissions scandal prosecutors say
douglas hodge was especially active for
nearly a decade
they say he paid rik singer mastermind
of the fraud $850,000 to get four of his
children into Georgetown in USC as phony
athletic recruits and he was wiretapped
allegedly trying to get a fifth child
into school the retired chief executive
of investment giant PIMCO begged the
judge for leniency admitting he
illegally tipped the scales in favor of
my children over others and expressed
his deepest and sincerest regret but
Judge Nathaniel Gordon called Hodges
conduct appalling and mind-boggling he
sentenced Taj to nine months in prison
find him $750,000 and ordered 500 hours
of community service that same judge
will oversee the case of Lauri Lachlan
who's charged with even more crimes
should Lauri Lachlan be concerned of
course I'm guarantee you she's freaking
out
because she's she's concerned that what
happened to Hodge is going to happen to
her the judge said he would have given
Hodge a year in prison but his thirty
million dollars in charitable donations
over the years earned him a discount on
his sentence Hodge will now report to
federal prison on March 20th for CBS
this morning Saturday Carter Evans Los
Angeles whoo she's got to be thinking
Lori Loughlin not over yet